>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mary Jane Deeb: Good
afternoon, ladies and gentlemen,
and thank you all for coming.
I'm Mary Jane Deeb, chief of the
African-Middle East Division,
and I'm really happy
to see you all here.
We always thought with a little
commercial about our division,
and as this is a program that
is recorded and that is going
to be seen and will
be able to be seen
in different parts of the world.
So the African-Middle
East Division,
in which you are
all seated here,
is made up of three sections;
the African section covers
the whole continent of Africa,
the whole continent,
subcontinent of Africa.
North Africa is included
in the Near East division,
and the reason being
language, because we're divided
by language more than by
geopolitical districting,
if you want.
The second division,
therefore, I've already started,
is the Near East division, which
includes the countries starting
from Morocco and going
through to Afghanistan.
It also includes
all the countries
of Central Asia and
the Caucasus.
And then the third section
is the Hebraic section,
for which we collect worldwide.
We're divided by language,
which means that the collections
in the vernacular are here in
our custody, and the collections
in Western languages are part
of the general collection.
So with respect to Angola, most
of the materials will be found
in the general collection,
although the specialists
are here
in the African-Middle
East Division.
We have, as all the
librarians of the library,
have three goals, three
missions, if you want.
One is to collect materials
from all over the world,
and when I say materials I mean
not just books and journals
and newspapers, but
also films and music
and photographs and maps.
We have the largest
collection in the world of maps.
And we collect broadly
from all over the world.
Our second mission is then to
preserve these collections,
and the library has
one of the best centers
for preservation of materials.
We preserve the rare
materials in boxes, in cases,
in areas in which temperature
and humidity is controlled.
We preserve more recent books,
sometimes by washing
them, believe or not.
We de-acidify the paper because
we receive a lot of materials
that are on acidic paper and
that are self-destroying.
And so we collect
these materials,
preserve them, shelve them.
And the third mission
is actually
to serve these materials to our
patrons, and our patrons come
from the whole world,
from our 78 countries
in this particular reading
room, but they come from all
over the world for
the whole library.
They're accessible, those
materials are available free
to everyone and can
be used for research.
We do not take a stand,
political or otherwise,
on what we collect,
and we collect materials
in all formats.
So, however, in order
to make the countries
that we're responsible for and
the materials better known,
we invite scholars,
as we have today
with Professor Linda Heywood.
We invite scholars to
discuss their research.
So what happens after we
have served our patrons,
we have given them the books?
Well, those patrons use
those materials, write books,
go out on lecture tours,
talk about the research
they have conducted,
and we invite them here to
talk about their research
and to get us all informed and
enlightened, both other patrons,
other researchers and
we librarians as well.
We learn from our guests, we
learn from the scholars who come
and who talk about
their research.
And so it's very exciting for me
to have Professor Heywood here
to talk about a subject
close to her heart and for
which we have a significant
collection.
And to introduce her is our
area specialist for Africa
and who is responsible
for Angola, and the person
who actually invited
Professor Heywood,
and that is Laverne Page who
will introduce the speaker.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Laverne Page: Thank you.
Again, welcome to the Library
of Congress and to the African
and Middle Eastern Division.
Our speaker is Professor Linda
Heywood, author of "Njinga
of Angola, Africa's
Warrior Queen," published
by Harvard University
Press in 2017.
After the lecture
she will sign --
well, after the lecture
there are copies available
of this book and Dr. Heywood
can sign them for you.
I'll give you a very
brief overview
of Professor Heywood's
writings and other activities.
She is a professor of African
History and the History
of the African Diaspora,
and African American
Studies at Boston University.
She is the author of "Contested
Power in Angola," editor of
and contributor to "Central
African Cultural Transformations
in the American Diaspora," and
coauthor with John Thornton
of "Central African, Atlantic
Creoles and the Foundation
of America," published
by Cambridge University
Press in 2017.
This book was also the winner
of the 2008 Melville
Herskovits Award
for the best book
published in African studies.
She is also one of the coeditors
of the 2015 published book
"African Americans in U.S.
Foreign Policy, From the Era
of Frederick Douglass to
the Age of Obama," published
by the University
of Illinois Press.
Okay.
This book was published
by the University
of Illinois Press in 2015.
Her articles on Angola and the
African diaspora have appeared
in the "Journal of
African History," "Journal
of Modern African Studies,"
"Slavery and Abolition,"
and the "Journal of
Southern African Studies".
She has served as a consultant
for numerous museum exhibitions.
She has also served as a history
consultant, and has appeared
in several Henry Louis
Gates' PBS series,
such as "Finding
Oprah's Roots" in 2007,
and the "African Civilizations,"
and that was for 2017.
And so now, Professor Heywood,
could you come to the podium
and talk to us about
Queen Njinga?
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Professor Heywood:
Well, thank you very much
for the introduction and for
that overview of the scope
of the library, both in
terms of its holdings as well
as its public engagement.
I'm really honored to be here.
I have been sort of carrying
Queen Njinga in my head
since I taught at
Howard University,
of course, on Central Africa.
I had to teach Central
Africa before 1800
and then Central
Africa since 1800,
as well as the African diaspora,
and I did not know what impact
I had had on the students.
They had a name which they
called me, which I'm not going
to repeat, but when Ta-Nehisi
Coates, who happened to be
in that Central African history,
as well as in the class I taught
on writing the African
diaspora at Howard University,
when they published his book
"Between the World and Me,"
I picked up the book and I said,
oh, Ta-Nehisi, another book,
you know, his Atlantic articles,
and I put it on my desk
because I was very
busy at the time.
Well, just soon afterwards
I got emails and calls
from former students who said,
Dr. Heywood, did you know that,
you know, your name is
on page 54 of Ta-Nehisi's
"Between the World and Me".
So the book was right on my desk
waiting for time, so I opened it
and there he revealed to me how
impactful my teaching his first
exposure to Queen Njinga was,
and I guess it was meeting
Queen Njinga, was also impactful
to me, but I did not start
off my career, you know,
thinking I'm going
to write a biography
of a famous African ruler.
I had no idea.
And so it's really been a
journey that I've taken,
and I have published the book,
the book is here,
as you can see.
So I'm not going to give you
a summary of the book, or so.
There were things in the book
that I could not develop as well
as I hoped I could
develop in articles.
One of those was
Njinga's diplomacy,
and I want to explore
that with you.
So this is a paper that
I'm putting together,
but a lot of it is informed
in my engagement with Njinga
in writing her biography.
So I'll start with Angola.
And all of you, I don't
know how to point this out,
but you see Angola on this
modern map, and we're going
to now give you some
information on Queen Njinga
and her background,
important dates.
You can get that in the book.
But, you know, 1582,
born sometime in 1582.
We know that.
We know she was baptized
in 1622.
She was the ruler of Ndongo,
the kingdom that her father,
her brother and other, you know,
older rulers had controlled
before the Portuguese, you know,
began their wars
against Ndongo in 1575
and it ended in the 1570s.
We call that the
Hundred Years War.
So the Hundreds Year War did
not only happen in Europe,
it also happened in Angola.
Then we had Njinga being thrown
out of her kingdom between 1626
and 1627, and she did
not just fade out.
She, in fact, continued
the struggle.
Her famous alliance with
some very ruthless Imbangala,
or Jagas, we call
that the Jaga phase.
Njinga's Dutch alliance is a
major point in her life as well.
And then at the end of her life
she returns to Christianity
and becomes the Christian
ruler of Matamba
until 1663, when she died.
The date of her death, we
have very detailed information
because the Capuchin
missionary who served
in her court was there
recording every iota of movement
that she did until
her last breath.
And you will see in my
description of that,
that I tried to recreate.
I even tried to find out
exactly what she died from.
You can read the book and see.
And so in 1622, when
Njinga first appeared
in official documentation
systematically, you will see
that the Portuguese had already
taken a big slice of Ndongo,
going from the base in Luanda,
the capital, where they had come
and conquered in 1575 -- oh, no.
They come in 1575, and then
increasingly Ndongo would lose
its territory.
So you see this in 1622.
But because of Njinga,
she actually,
by the end of her
life, she actually --
the Portuguese increased their
holdings, but she actually added
to her kingdom, Matamba.
Ndongo, she kept a little part
of Ndongo, the eastern part.
And as you can see this
region, the eastern borders
of Njinga's territory, actually
went across the Congo River.
It went down into areas we
now know as the Lunda area.
So it's very, very interesting
that Njinga made
her mark on Angola.
No other leader has done that.
So I said, okay, since
I'm doing, you know,
an overview of diplomacy, a
written as well as performed
and oral, I said let me tell
you who are the recorders
and receivers of Njinga's, you
know, diplomatic, you know,
openings of Portuguese
officials.
Njinga outlived 11 Portuguese
governors, and there were some
that she dealt with
systematically
who recorded her
letters and her actions.
Fernao de Sousa and Luis
Martins de Sousa Chichorro.
Portuguese soldier,
this one individual,
Antonio de Cadornega,
he lived in Angola.
He came as a teenager and went
through these various phases
of his career, dying in 1690,
he was a recorder of Njinga.
He was on the scene, talked to
her, had arguments with her.
Also we have Italian
Capuchin missionaries
who arrived in 1654.
Others would come, but I just
wanted to identify the two
that were really important;
Father Antonio Gaeta
and Father Antonio
Giovanni Cavazzi.
You'll hear me only speaking
about their last names
instead of going over.
And they did not come from
just anyplace in Europe.
They came from Rome,
from the Vatican.
Also, Njinga had contact
with, sent letters
to Portuguese rulers
and the two kings
who ruled during Njinga's
time was King Joao, IV,
as well as King Afonso.
And last, but not least,
Njinga wrote letters
to Pope Alexander VII, and
he was Pope 1655 to 1667.
So Njinga had in her scope --
you know, she was not just
confined to an African land.
This was a person who was
playing global politics
and global diplomacy.
So I wanted to sort of
thinking about, okay,
if I'm thinking about, you
know, diplomacy and writing and,
you know, what's the nature
of, you know, diplomacy,
so I just wanted to
introduce you to a couple
of the scholars I've
been looking at,
you know, and what is writing.
And I like this, As a vector
conveying words, a writ,
a written document, and we are
here with written document,
is performative of an
action in a given territory.
So it combines the both things.
You have a written document,
but you have a performance,
and that's what intrigues
me about Njinga.
And then I wanted to say,
well, what are people thinking,
you know, in the past, really
in antiquity, you know,
Rome and before Rome
and the classical world,
how did people communicate?
Wow. In antiquity, only face
communication would guarantee
the reliable transmission
of the words and opinions
of one person to another.
This is really fundamental.
And you know we live in
a capital where politics
and all the diplomats are here,
so I don't have to explain
to you that when you really
want to get things done,
you go in person, you
know, you send that person
who is your right arm
to deliver your message
and to be persuasive.
I also said, okay, Njinga is
living in a world in Europe,
you know, there's
the Medieval Period.
This is Tudor Period in England.
And I said what was
Elizabeth doing.
Because, in fact, we had
a play on Queen Njinga,
"Queen Njinga, The Queen King".
It was shown, it opened
at Folger some years ago,
and I said, look, it's -- you
know, this is the Tudor world,
this is the Medieval world,
this is Elizabeth's world.
I think in some respects
Elizabeth and Njinga,
Catherine the Great
of, you know, Russia,
all of these women rulers
were very much, you know,
in the scope of performing.
So here I have "Elizabeth I of
England, Dance and Diplomacy".
This is an article I ran across.
I said, wow.
So I got another entry
into how diplomacy is done.
Diplomacy could be danced,
it could be performed.
It's a performance.
Communication is a
performative act.
And I also said, well, what
else is this writer telling me,
and I like this.
Ben Johnson's 1603 Masque.
You know, if you go to
France, you'll see the masques.
All the courts of
Europe had this.
I came out of Europe in
history, so I'm not afraid to go
in European history
and find our parallels,
you know, with Njinga's world.
So the "Satyr".
"They came to see
and to be seen,
and though they dance before
the queen, they're none of those
that hope to come by/Wealth
to build another
Hombly/Hatton's estate."
And it tells you that people in
England, in Europe as a whole,
you know, that performance,
how you appeared in court,
your ability to dance and
move and know the moves
and know the etiquette, is
something that is just --
you know, we forget this.
You know, we are gross now.
But there was a time when, you
know, knowing how to appear,
how the etiquette, you
know, of speak, of speech,
of movement was very crucial
to indicate your intentions,
and people read you.
So the first thing I want to
introduce you to is Njinga.
Some people have seen this
picture, but it is, in fact,
Njinga in her first
performance, you know,
her diplomacy, you know.
She went to negotiate
with the Portuguese
on behalf of her brother.
And the Portuguese governor,
you know, sits on his chair,
you know, and as
usual, they gave the --
put on the floor a carpet
for the defeated African
to sit lower and show
their subordination.
And Njinga calls one
of her attendants,
you could call her
slave, client,
I don't care what you
call her, but Njinga had
to show her status was
equal to the Portuguese
and she negotiated
getting up and down,
and the Portuguese are just
blown away, is this what --
and she was so persuasive
they sealed a deal.
Now, the Portuguese
would renege,
but in Njinga's presence
they sealed that deal,
that the Portuguese would
remove their fort in Ambaca.
Okay. When they didn't do it,
Njinga will take
up the struggle.
Another thing that Njinga
performed was that, you know,
they persuaded her -- or Njinga
persuaded herself, I will say,
that, you know, what
is strategic.
The Portuguese had something.
They had Christian, a
religion, and Njinga was staying
in the house of one
of the wealthy,
you know, families in Luanda.
And yes, six months
there she did convert.
Well, she did allow
herself to be baptized
and to learn the catechism.
And here she is very
-- you see this
and you say this is
Cavazzi's drawing.
It doesn't come from today,
we are not creating things,
this is from the time period.
And Cavazzi was speaking
to people who, in fact,
lived in Njinga's court.
He got all these traditions,
how she was born, everything.
So I believe this, even though
he is a, oh, European outsider,
but you have to weigh how you
take those written documents
that come to you, and
there's some things, you know,
that you can question
and there are some things
that are genuine.
So you look and see what's the
environment in which the scholar
or this observer's taken
down that material.
And we know that when
Njinga left the court,
when she left Luanda, she was
given all sort of Christian,
you know, crosses, and so
on, to take back with her.
And once Njinga reached
outside of the --
you know, she was accompanied
up to the end of the city.
There was, imagine, you
know, the bush and the urban.
So once she got back to Omatu
[phonetic], the Angolans were
on the side of the
bush, you know,
she just called her own
religious, you know, supporters
and had them do the
ritual so that
when she could get back safe,
back to her Ambaca,
back to her lands.
Okay. So I'm just saying,
I believe that these two,
even though the Portuguese
might indicate for this
that Njinga was baptized
and genuine,
I think it was all
strategic diplomacy.
This was the first
evidence of her diplomacy.
So here I begin with Njinga's
strategic diplomacy, the writ,
you know, the written document.
And her father had died and, you
know, they're reporting this,
but he said Dona Ana Sousa
-- her brother had died.
Dona Ana Sousa, his
sister, who is baptized,
you see again the Portuguese
say this, she's baptized, right,
has been nominated, but
she's not named queen,
only Lady of Angola.
Oh, but the thing about
diplomacy, Njinga strategically,
I have received a letter of hers
in which she says that as soon
as the fort is removed,
she will immediately come
out of the lands where she is.
So Njinga continued
her brother's struggle,
and she wanted to negotiate.
She wanted to make sure
that the Portuguese played
by the rules of diplomacy.
And if they wanted war,
she will get to war,
and that war could be
prolonged, she'll prolong it
until she overcame,
or show the Portuguese
that she was not going to
subordinate herself to them.
So here, Njinga's
oral diplomacy,
not only is she sending
letters, she sends --
you know how Njinga
returned to the islands,
right, she called the sobas.
She is negotiating
with the supporters.
Some of these sobas are
all on the Portuguese side.
Njinga is going to bring
them in alliance with her
against the Portuguese.
All right.
With this intention, she
sent her mani lumbo --
and all of these
negotiators have diplomats,
her emissaries, they
have titles.
This is not just bush.
This is a state.
Her mani lumbo from the lands of
Ambaca to open the slave trade.
Okay. She trade some slaves.
That's what the Portuguese
have taken.
The Portuguese themselves
are trading in slaves.
So don't bring anything
to me to tell me, oh,
but Njinga's trading in slaves.
I will just tell you,
oh, the Portuguese
and the Europeans were
trading in slaves also.
Now, I'm a descendent of these
slaves so I should be hurt.
No, I'm not hurt.
History is history.
You go beyond that.
You go forward.
You look backward to understand
it and you know you don't want
to stay there or be
that, so you go forward.
So that's what you have
to understand with Njinga.
She always was looking to the
future, to the future for her
to maintain her autonomy so
that the Portuguese would never
control her land.
Okay. And we have not
only the mani lumbo.
I'm not going to
read all of these.
But each of these are
titled, you know, mani lumbo,
her privado, her
macunzes, her pungas.
All of these are officials that
again and again Njinga sends,
you know what I mean,
with letters,
you know, with performance.
And the Portuguese, sometimes
you see this [inaudible] I cut
off his head.
I don't know if I told you that.
Right. I ordered him seized
as a spy and slit his throat
in the fortress where
he came to negotiate.
Okay. So Njinga knows that.
Right. So she is never going
to trust the Portuguese,
but she sends people
to negotiate,
but she's always
thinking look behind
because they're not
to be trusted.
I'm sorry for the Portuguese
that I'm presenting it
like this, but this is history.
I'm not against the Portuguese.
I love Portugal, but this
is really exciting history.
Okay. So they said how
was this performed.
Look at this.
You know, Cadornega, he
said, look, these people,
this queen is Njinga
Ana de Sousa,
she's very conscious
of her high status.
This guy was there
as a young man.
He has seen her grow.
He has grown with the wars.
He has grown with her.
You know, so when
he's reflecting,
he knows her, you know.
And the nation of Angola,
which is really Mbundu
and the word Kimbundu --
and I spell Njinga, N-j,
that's the Kimbundu spelling.
Okay. So my book
is "Queen Njinga,"
right, "Njinga of Angola".
It's the Kimbundu spelling.
There's several other
spellings, Z-i-n or, you know,
S-i-n, Italian spelling.
In fact, I am doing now another
book on Njinga, the second book
on her memory, and she's in
America, and she is in America
in the 19th century,
in the 18th century.
I'm going to show you that,
not now, but Z-i-n-g-h-a.
Right. Fascinating.
Anyhow, so you see, the people
from which she originate,
you know, they take
great pleasure, right,
they think their
lands are extensive.
These are proud people.
But what get me, she sends her
ambassadors, right, they spoke
and gave her embassy in
their own Mbundu language.
Absolutely.
Pride in the language.
In fact, turning the Colonial
Period, late Colonial, 1900s,
the Portuguese are
contesting with Njinga still,
and they said -- they call the
Mbundu language dog language,
and the Njingas -- this
is in the 20th century,
this is in 1950s,
and the Njingas,
they said Portuguese is,
in fact, the language of --
I'm not going to say what it is.
But if you insult me,
I'm going to insult you.
Up to today that tendency
of resistance and authority
and sort of belief in your
language, your people,
your land, it's very strong.
So she said they spoke,
right, and it was explained
by an interpreter -- by the
way, every Portuguese governor,
every Portuguese [inaudible]
their post at this time,
they had to hire an interpreter
who spoke in Kimbundu.
So as I've shown in
an article I wrote,
Kimbundu was the lingua franca
of Luanda, not Portuguese.
In fact, "Portuguese
into Africa,"
I called an article I wrote
because I can see
that sort of melding.
You have a new society
being created in Luanda,
not in Ndongo, not in Matamba.
That's still, you
know, Mbundu land,
Kimbundu land, Njinga's land.
Right. Their speech
is well rehearsed.
This is the interpreter.
Right. They're well-rehearsed.
And there are people who will
stand a whole day speaking
in their language without
resting, and speak at times
so obscurely that even
native-born person
can't understand.
These are trained, you know,
speakers, oral speakers.
This is not oral
tradition I'm talking about.
This is negotiating politics.
Okay. So, you know, you go
to Africa and you say, oh,
I want to learn the
African tradition.
No. These people, the tradition
is a living tradition, you know,
and they're proud of it.
Njinga Ana de Sousa, her
diplomacy, every new governor
who arrived, Njinga gets
all her messages from Luanda
with her spies, and
she then sends letters,
or sends ambassadors.
It's just incredible, you know,
tenacity of this
incredible woman.
Njinga sent an embassy
to the city with letters
that she dictated asking
for a respectful settler
to discuss matters of
importance to the two crowns.
Right. So Njinga, every time
she hear a new governor comes,
she tries to start over.
You know, she said look, I've
given you so many slaves,
so many bundles of things
that you have asked for,
and you're just cheating me,
I know you're cheating me,
so I'm going to look
for another way.
I am not going to let any
Portuguese priest come
in my land.
She doesn't want a
Portuguese priest.
If you are sending
an interpreter,
if you're sending a
negotiator, guess what,
they got to speak Kimbundu.
They're not coming in my
land and speak Portuguese.
That's what she -- she
determined what her, you know,
the way in which she would
negotiate with the Portuguese.
Right. Guess what.
So it's not only the
Portuguese she is dealing with.
The Dutch took over
Luanda, Angola 1641 to 1648.
The first thing Njinga
does is what,
send her people to the Dutch.
She said, look, we
can work together.
I don't want the
Portuguese here,
you don't want the
Portuguese here, let's ally.
And, in fact, up to
the very end Njinga
and the Dutch would
have controlled Angola,
but there's in Europe another
negotiation had taken place
where the Dutch decided that
they had to leave Luanda
because their crowns
had come together
and Njinga brings
down her troops.
You'll see all this.
Exciting. They're waiting
for her, right, they're going
to end the Portuguese.
She comes down and sees
the Dutch ship leaving.
Right, leaving.
So another group of
Europeans have reneged
on the negotiations
they made with her.
So you ask me why Njinga
went Imbangala, ballistic.
She did because she had been --
time and time again the
Europeans, the Portuguese
and now the Dutch
had disappointed her.
Okay. We state here in
the reports that we have
yet to find the occasion to send
our letters to Queen Ana Njinga.
From the reports in
question you would learn
that you have received
letters from this queen,
again showing you that
Njinga took the initiative,
you know, to send letters.
Okay. Njinga was
also very much alert
to the new missionaries
who were coming in.
So it's 1652, you know,
missionary, right, I want to get
to the lands -- this is
in her Imbangala stage.
I want to get to the
lands of this woman.
We heard that she's
a barbarian, wow,
the Portuguese have thrown her
out, right, and now she lives
like a captive bird, right, but
she had said this captive bird,
right, knows what is
going on in Luanda.
Guess what.
She sends an ambassador.
She sends an ambassador, right,
and then he sends a letter
to her in which I ask her
please give up your ways,
come back to the church.
Njinga knows what she's doing.
So she's invaded Congo and
the Congo eastern area Wandu
[phonetic], and there are
two missionaries were there
in Congo, and guess what,
her army captured the two
missionaries and brings them
to Njinga, Father
Cordella and Father Veas,
and they're shaking, because
all they've heard of Njinga is
that she's an Imbangala,
they are cannibals,
they eat their [inaudible]
children, all this stuff.
So they're there and her
captain brings them to her.
And she's just calm then.
She said, calmer.
Like the Portuguese told me,
when the Angolans told me
when I got, you know,
excited and I got sick,
they'll just say calmer
Linda, calmer Linda, calmer,
because I get excited sometimes.
It's fascinating.
And I could see Njinga saying,
calmer, Capuchinos, calmer.
And she sets to make
them at ease.
You're not going to be eaten.
You're not going
to eat human flesh.
She tells them in conversation,
she has long conversations
with them in the time that they
are, you know, in her, you know,
present in her kilombo,
military,
you know, marooned outpost.
She said, [foreign language].
We people don't eat human
flesh, but my soldiers,
who are Imbangala, who comes
from a different ethnicity,
we have to satisfy them
because we need to use them,
and guess what, she
didn't say that,
but I'm adding she could have
said the Portuguese are doing
the same thing, they're
using the Imbangalas
and they know they eat human
flesh or have all this thing,
you know, cannibalism,
that's what they write.
Many people question that
now, but I'm just saying
that that was the world.
The more you could
intimidate your enemy,
is an upper hand you have.
Leaders do horrible things.
They make sometimes choices
that we consider horrible,
but sometimes survival of the
fittest fits in and our leaders
that we -- and we didn't
even elect these leaders.
These leaders gained their
prominence from lineage,
from inheritance, like
Queen Elizabeth II today.
I admire her.
She's lived so many
years, you know,
and she's continuing
the monarchy.
That's what Njinga wanted to do.
So what? We are democrats
and we don't like people
with inheritance, but
we're, oh, we tolerate them.
Okay. We don't let them vote.
Okay. So Njinga has
peace negotiations.
An ambassador of Njinga
arrived in Luanda.
He appears at the
palace, accompanied --
the Portuguese had, in
fact, imprisoned her sister.
I can't go into all the details.
It's in the book.
But Njinga sends a letter to
her sister who is in prison
in Luanda to negotiate
the release of her sister.
Why? Njinga does not
want any Imbangala,
any Jaga to inherit the kingdom.
She wants a family [inaudible].
She said I wish I had a son.
Her brother had killed her son,
according to the tradition,
and she had killed
her brother's son.
You know, these royal intrigues,
if you do European history,
you see all of that.
Remember Richard III, you
know, killing all those --
you know, I can tell you
all the gory details.
I love them, I love
history like that.
I'm glad we don't have it now,
but history's really
interesting if you go back.
The ambassador verbally details
the contents of the letter.
During the speech the
ambassador presented ten slaves
that Njinga sent as a gift
to the Queen of Portugal.
The king had died and the
queen was just in transition
as the king's son took
over, Afonso [inaudible].
So Njinga's already
strategizing I'm going to get
on the good side of the
queen in terms of diplomacy,
and you'll see her
working through that.
Right. Here's a letter.
I found this letter.
It gave me goose pimples.
Oh, my gosh, a letter that
would actually -- you see that?
You know what that is inside
there, what we call it?
Yeah. Seal.
The seal we say, you know.
Impressa [phonetic].
You know, is that genuine, man.
And look at her, right, and
she had her Congo secretary.
And this is going because --
you know, I mean, so we have --
I can't go into all the details,
but it's just an incredible
set of documentation.
The peace negotiations
always send bearing letters,
they sent it to Njinga's court.
She performs the receipt
of the letter, you know.
Father Gaeta, you
know, she has them
as her allies men,
spiritual diplomacy.
Go to Luanda.
I'm going to send an
ambassador straight to Rome
so that they can talk and
kiss the feet of the Pope
so he can send me missionaries.
Don't let the Portuguese know
because Portuguese has a law
that no African could
leave as an ambassador
on their own to go to Europe.
And you're telling me why
Njinga should not be suspicious
of the Portuguese.
So she used these spiritual
diplomats who are working
on her soul, you know,
as her emissaries.
She said if my representatives
cannot go,
then you go on my behalf.
And we have several letters to
that, you know, [inaudible],
with the excuse that I'm sending
my ambassador with the excuse
to send the condolences
for the death of King John.
Right. After this
embassy then he'll go on.
He'll be kept in a
Capuchin, you know --
you know, he will be
upkept by the Capuchins
and then they will safely
send him on to Rome.
Okay. And we have all the
intrigue of the letters.
I can't go into all
of that, the time.
Okay. Finally, I
have to stop, okay.
I want to show you this.
So it's got a lot of
secrecy with this.
She gets a letter from the Pope.
Right. She sends the Pope the
letter, she gets a letter.
She gets letters.
Njinga performs.
I can't go into all the details.
She performs when she
gets these letters,
big parade that she
was a performer.
She wore around her neck
beautiful gold brocade.
All of this, this is a
description of a woman
who is a woman, she's gendered,
but she's also just a leader,
a diplomat, a [inaudible],
one of the best,
right, one of the best.
And she thanks him, even at the
end of her life, by the way.
This is in April.
Njinga's going to
be dead by December.
Right. Because she wants
to protect the autonomy
of her kingdom, she still
sends we are lacking,
we don't have enough
Capuchins, send Capuchins.
Okay. And this letter
arrived after Njinga had died,
a letter from the Pope.
"To our Dear Daughter in
Christ Regina Ana Njinga."
Okay. So this is the woman
that we are dealing with.
This is no, you know,
fly-by-night, you know, leader.
This is a leader who had
an impact on her people.
That is why her memory
is retained.
You know, people carrying
me to see footsteps,
this is where Njinga stepped.
Amazing. So I have to
do the second book.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
If you have any questions,
I'm open to --
you know, I know I went over
things very quickly, but.
Yes.
>> Where did you find
this documentation,
such as the letters?
>> Professor Heywood: Well,
some of the letters are embedded
in Cadornega's book,
for instance.
Some of them are embedded
in Cavazzi's manuscript.
Some of them I found --
the letter I showed you,
I found this in Lisbon at the
Arquivo Historico Ultramarino,
that's the overseas archives,
which is the main archive.
I also visited Venice, Florence,
because the Capuchin has
an archive in Venice,
and some of the Capuchins, there
was a Capuchin Secado [phonetic]
who came to Angola I think
in 1950s, but in any case,
in '57 he actually found --
he went to visit the site that
people said was Njinga's grave,
and he actually measured
it and he had --
the Capuchin had all
the specifications
of the hasidi [phonetic]
and he stipulated that
that was the grave.
So we had collected
all the archives.
I also went to the
Papacy, you know,
in Rome to look for documents.
And sometimes I got documents
from the Dutch, you know,
the West India Company.
So it's all over.
Not in America though.
It's in 17th and
18th, but mostly 17th
and late 16th century
documentation.
The writing is pretty
horrible, some of it,
so sometimes I had really
nice, supportive students
who were Italian speakers or
were from, you know, Portugal,
Portuguese speakers who checked
out things and then I checked it
and I did a lot of -- the poem
from Cavazzi that I quoted
at the end of the book, where
he's -- it wasn't published,
it was in his manuscript.
The first time it's
published is in my book.
And he says that Njinga is --
you know, he compares Njinga --
in fact, I could
actually, just a minute --
yeah, I know I'm going
on, but this is important.
So just it will take a sec.
Okay. "Under this rice cloth,
fielded cloth, in the dark tomb
that you see, Njinga, who
made herself queen of Ndongo
and Matamba, lies
buried, a dry corpse.
In this dark tomb that you see,
here lies the one
who lived to die.
Here lies the one
who by dying lives.
In this dark tomb
she hid herself.
Because of Agrippa
Rome repelled.
Because of Helen
Greece rebelled.
Because of Yusodonia
[phonetic] Germany rebelled.
Because of Hecuba,
Spain rebelled.
But Ethiopia did not
rebel for Njinga.
Instead, Njinga overturned,
destroyed and ruined Ethiopia.
Njinga in death stole
from Heaven's treasure.
In this tomb her
body is locked up.
Therefore, we can sing
to a most cunning thief.
A most cunning thief has stolen
from the treasury of Heaven.
Njinga outsmarted even death."
And that's why her
memory lives on.
So I wanted to contextualize.
So this letter is in
the manuscript section.
It was never published
in Cavazzi's book.
So that's the type of thing.
You have to really
compare what is, you know,
the translated version and
then go back to the original
to make sure you're
not missing anything.
And there are a lot of
interesting sections of details
that go into give you
insight into the mind
of this incredible
woman that assisted me.
Yes.
>> Thank you.
I mean, this is very exciting.
She really is.
You know, I had always
figured, without any doubt.
You mentioned a couple of
issues [inaudible] before.
What were some of the other
issues which she was negotiating
with the Portuguese, and then
with the Dutch, again
the Portuguese?
What were some of the --
>> Professor Heywood: Well,
the main thing was she
wanted the Portuguese
to let her retain
the whole of Ndongo,
the parts that they had taken.
She wanted them to -- the
Portuguese had put in her place,
after they had expelled her or
created conditions where she had
to go into resistance.
She wanted them to
get rid of the king
that they had nominated.
The Portuguese had said
that Njinga was not
legitimate because --
[ Inaudible comment ]
Yeah. Yes, the Angolans
and Ndongo never,
you know, had women.
In the book I tried to show
that in this sort of --
in the traditions of this area
that women were very crucial
as central players
in the kingship.
So the thing was to
recognize her legitimacy,
recognize her rights
to the areas of Angola
that her brother had left
and her father had left.
Up to her father's --
the Portuguese had
moved in up to Ambaca.
She wanted them to
get, you know, removal.
Yes. With the Dutch, she hoped
that the Dutch would just
help her get totally, push --
[ Inaudible comment ]
No Portuguese presence
in Angola.
She also -- I didn't mention
this in the article I'm going
to write on this diplomacy,
she also had a lot of diplomacy
with Africans, especially the
King of Congo, and she would,
in fact -- she was planning --
she said the only rulers I
respect is the King of Congo.
So that there were a lot of
things that Njinga was a --
if there was a -- I'm not
talking about protonationalist.
She was a nationalist
from the beginning.
We have these terms
protonational.
She knew what nationalism was.
She was the, you know,
ruler of her land.
So those types of things.
And she did not want the
Portuguese to come into Matamba
and -- but through Portuguese
speaking missionaries
who would be spies
for the Portuguese
and undermine her rule.
But she did not mind
using the Portuguese,
so that she would send them
gifts, she would also send
to get the church
that she built.
It was all -- all the interior
of the church design was all
done by Portuguese and mulatto,
mixed people, skilled
craftsmen who were in Massangano
and Luanda, and she paid them.
So she did not mind, you
know, learning all the new
or adopting all the new styles,
whether it was in a dress,
she asked the governor to send
her earrings, she does this.
She's very woman here.
But she also was
a strategic ruler.
It didn't mean that she wanted
-- because she was, you know,
dealing with you and
trading with you,
that she would let
the [inaudible] be
that you could come and
take over her territory
because she had --
Njinga was born in 1582.
The Portuguese, a few
maybe months after her --
her family had to
flee from the capital.
So she grew up in a situation
of, you know, being a refugee,
coming back and,
you know, survival.
Yeah. It was instinctive
to survive for Njinga.
Yes. Yes, sir.
>> Could you say a little more
about the memory of Njinga
in America [inaudible]?
>> Professor Heywood: Okay.
I'm going to give
you some teasers.
When I sort of -- the book I'm
writing on her, "Njinga Memory,
Culture and History," I
had, in fact, done research
in Angola, interviewed people.
I had read all the Portuguese
references after Njinga's death,
all the different, you
know, publications,
and I had also followed Njinga
to Brazil where she's remembered
in the con gatas and the
only named person in any
of the con gatas, this is
an Afro-Brazilian festival,
is Njinga.
So I have quality stuff there.
Then I decided, because I'm
a modern African specialist,
you know, I decided I have
to follow Njinga and see
if she appears in Cuba because
of the Cuban connection.
And one day I was walking
down the street in Havana --
I've gone to Havana five times.
This is my sixth, you know,
sixth time I'll be going.
And I saw on the street
a children's magazine
and I saw this picture with
this, you know, Nzinga.
I said, oh, my gosh,
Njinga's here.
So I've been collecting research
of all the captains
of the Cuban Army.
They're writing their memos
now and everybody has to start
with the history of Angola, the
resistance history of Angola
and it's right, they
start with Njinga
because that's [inaudible],
you know, history of Angola.
That's what it is.
So I sort of had said
I would stop there,
and after the book came out
in February, I gave a talk
at my old institution,
Boston University,
and the question I invariably
got from the three speakers
who were commenting on it, where
is the second book, you know.
So I said, well, I have part of
it and then I decide, you know,
I had collected some
things on Njinga.
I had worked with BSA,
Black Sisterhood in Action,
in the '90s who every year
celebrate a famous African queen
or ruler, and the year I worked
with them they celebrated
Queen Njinga.
So I had done that, but it was,
you know, it was 20th century.
And if I were to do a
chapter on Njinga in America,
I have to push it back to see.
So that's when I started.
I came to LC just last summer,
just to begin, you know,
seeing if there's
anything in the newspapers.
And I'm finding it.
Abolition is literature,
you know.
I'm finding it in the first
encyclopedia published
in America, you know,
having references to Njinga.
I'm finding it in feminist --
it's going to be incredible.
I can't go into it, but
I'm just so excited.
I am just so excited
to finish that chapter,
so I'm collecting
the material now.
I'm teasing out the
way I'm going to do it.
It's going to be great,
so that's the American.
Yes, sir.
[ Inaudible comments ]
Yes.
[ Inaudible comment ]
Right, right.
Yeah.
[ Inaudible comment ]
Yeah. Absolute.
What I hope to do in the --
if it's published in America,
and I've picked up some things
that were published in America,
I hope to address this in
the last part of the chapter
on America because there
are things now being --
a lot of stuff being
published on Njinga in America.
And as I said, I did not want
to start with the contemporary,
so I now have fleshed
out the 19th century.
I'm doing that, 18th and
19th century, and when I come
to the last part of the
book, you know, the chapter,
I'll be addressing the
distortions that I see
in the published
literature on Angola,
especially children's books.
I'll definitely.
And I'd like you to give me that
reference because I don't know
if I have the same as yours.
>> I don't remember,
but I remember I went
to the Northeast Public
Library in [inaudible].
>> Professor Heywood: Okay.
[ Inaudible comment ]
Okay. So I'll look.
I'll get them.
I'll have a graduate
student looking
at all the children's
literature.
Okay.
>> One more question?
>> Professor Heywood: Okay.
>> Well, I don't
have a question.
I just wanted to make
a comment, if I can.
>> Professor Heywood: Right.
Sure.
>> [Inaudible] around from
the kingdom, [inaudible],
and that was really a
pleasure for us to be
around and be part of this.
You talked about aspersions.
That was one of the
key features --
>> Professor Heywood: Right.
>> [Inaudible] from
your third book.
>> Professor Heywood: Yes.
>> [Inaudible] there's
a lot to be said.
>> Professor Heywood: Yeah.
>> But one thing we
should always remember is
that Njinga is known
[inaudible] today.
>> Professor Heywood:
Yeah, yeah.
>> Not just as a warrior,
but as a [inaudible].
>> Professor Heywood: Yes.
Right.
>> And wisdom.
>> Professor Heywood: Yes.
>> And beauty.
>> Professor Heywood: Yeah.
>> Because you were
talking about [inaudible].
>> Professor Heywood: Yes.
>> She was beautiful doing that.
>> And there's something
really interesting about her
because the new generation
are thinking most
of the time things
that [inaudible].
>> Professor Heywood: Yes.
Yeah.
>> Which is interesting.
I remember that when
we were growing up,
we used to read that
in a primary --
>> Professor Heywood:
Secondary school.
>> It didn't make sense.
>> Professor Heywood: Yes.
>> It only made sense later.
>> Professor Heywood: Right.
>> And then we started
calling our kids --
>> Professor Heywood: Yes.
>> Njinga.
>> You know.
>> Professor Heywood: The name.
>> The name.
>> Professor Heywood: Yeah.
[ Inaudible comment ]
Yes. Right.
>> [Inaudible] that
might be another chapter.
>> Professor Heywood: Yeah.
>> Looking for people in America
as a [inaudible] to,
you know, to find --
>> Professor Heywood: Yeah.
>> a connection --
>> to their --
>> Professor Heywood: Oh,
it's just part of the chapter.
And I have interviewed
lots of Angolans in Luanda.
I went up to Malange.
I interviewed some of the
sobas and just ordinary people.
I took the 11-hour trip from
Malange to Marimba so that
on each, you know, part
of the travel it was tough
because the roads are --
you know, we had to stop
and build bridges and so -- but
it was absolutely incredible.
And I have that, you
know, the perspective
of the different Angolans
from different regions
because I also collected
questionnaires from Mawambo
and from the Congo area.
And so it will be represented in
the last of the Angolan chapter
because I do Njinga in
contemporary Angola.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Professor Heywood: Okay.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.